Lara Hawketts and her husband live with their
kids in a two-story house
in the Forest Hills neighborhood of Washington,
D.C.
In 2009, Hawketts lost her job working for
a British consulting firm.
Looking for ways to pick up extra income,
Hawketts discovered that she could host short-term
guests for a modest fee
through a new service called Airbnb.
So they would stay in our basement
where they would, one person will be on the
sofa,
two people would be in the queen bed.
We'd have a pullout couch and a day bed and
the whole family would just squish up
and they didn't care.
And the experience they got from that was
so different
to something you would get in a hotel.
Airbnb has seen explosive growth in Washington,
D.C.,
which is among the nation’s most transient
cities.
As we started meeting neighbors and friends
who were like,
wow, this is so cool, it's been so great for
you guys.
“How do we do it?
Oh, we don't want to get involved in all of
that.
So, along with her husband, Hawketts started
Home Sweet City,
a business managing Airbnb rentals for other
hosts.
Today they oversee more than 60 properties...
And we just hear these amazing stories of
folks that would come to the city,
save for sometimes their entire lives, bring
their family
and it be there one trip of a lifetime to
DC
and there was no way they could afford to
stay in a hotel.
Today, a mid-scale hotel room in Washington
D.C. runs on average $237 per night.
For the about the same price you can rent
this centrally located four bedroom historic townhouse,
or for $110 this modern basement apartment
near Capitol Hill.
Or, for travelers on a budget, there’s this
twin bed in a shared room near Dulles airport for $16.
Hearing no further discussion,
all those in favor of the bill say aye, aye,
opposed...
it passes unanimously.
On November 13th, with the support of the
hotel Worker’s Union
and the industry’s trade group,
the DC city council passed a bill
that could have a devastating impact on the
district’s short-term rental market.
Airbnb hosts can no longer rent out properties
in which they don’t reside.
Those renting out their own spare rooms and
couches will be required to obtain a license,
report their activities to the city on a monthly
basis,
and be present during a stay, with the exception
of up to 90 days a year.
City Council Chairman Phil Mendelson says
the intent of the bill
is to eliminate competition from airbnb rentals,
and make it cheaper for permanent residents
to live in Washington, D.C.
So we limit the short term rentals to a person's
primary residence
and prohibited to a second or third property…
We think that that correlates to improving
the housing supply in terms of affordability.
But there’s a danger this new bill could
unintentionally wipe out the Airbnb market all together.
As the council has started to look at short
term housing as a market
and what the issues might be,
there's been a little bit of a rush to regulate
without realizing that D.C.s current zoning
actually prohibits short term housing in most
zones.
Tracy Loh, a data scientist at George Washington
University,
points out that even though most Airbnb rentals
are already illegal,
the City has never enforced the zoning code.
This new law could change that.
If the city gets involved in regulating airbnb
and requires the platform to register, get
a permit and share data,
then they will know where airbnb activity
is happening in the city
and that means that they'll know where there
are code violations.
If the zoning part of that bill, um, restricts
us from renting a basement here in this way,
we probably won't be able to stay in this
house.
The fact that we rent our basement so frequently,
it pays two thirds of our mortgage
All 13 members have asked the zoning commission
please,
In fact, on an emergency basis, we'd like
you to revise their zoning regulations
to permit short term rentals in a person's
primary residence.
Some of our owners have actually just said
woah
you know the ones that are a little bit nervous
of the situation and want to plan ahead.
They've said 'okay we're going to stop this
and we're going to get a long term tenant.'
But it's very few, a couple have gone that
route early,
even before it's passed or anything's passed.
And some are completely the opposite,
I'm going to do this whether they try and
stop me or not, you know?
I'm just going to take the risk and run with
it.
Chairman Mendelson says that airbnb hosts
should embrace the new law
because, assuming the zoning code changes,
it provides a legal pathway for them to operate.
There does need to be some minimum level of
regulation
with regard to a kind of transient accommodation
There had been complaints about party houses
there had been complaints about how there's
all this transient activity,
but the property owner isn't there.
There's not a person that has an investment
in the community.
Mister McDuffie's bill made me feel like I'm
back in the USSR.
The bill would make it hard if not impossible
for me to maintain my home of almost 25 years
in D.C.
I've bumped into a lot of small business owners
and they're bringing in their letters
And they're saying 'look I run this business,
I depend on this additional income,'
So there's so many stories like that that
it just can't be a bad thing,
We created a company out of necessity
and out of sheer determination and blood,
sweat and tears,
we built it from nothing in a new market,
in something that has never been done before
in an urban market.
And here we are and it feels like it's going
to be taken away from us.
And our business might have to change but
we're gonna sure as hell try and keep it going.